brexit shut down one of the UK's most
famous manufacturing facilities the
Oxford mini plant will stop producing
cars immediately after we leave the
European Union for at least a month
after its owners the car giant BMW
activated the next stage of its No Deal
contingency plan from my discussions
with BMW and I happen quite regularly I
know they are committed to staying in
Oxford because they've got an excellent
workforce here very highly skilled and
the plant is enormous ly productive but
I knew they will be frustrated that many
of the issues that BMW and others were
talking about before and that were
dismissed is somehow being political are
actually coming home to roost in a
statement BMW confirmed the move was
down to brexit it said as a responsible
organization we have scheduled next
year's annual maintenance period at mini
plant Oxford to start on the 1st of
April when the UK exits the EU to
minimise the risk of any possible
short-term parts supply disruption in
the event of an Odile brexit well we
believe this worst-case scenario is an
unlikely outcome we have to plan for it
go news visited exactly this plant a
year ago and was told clearly about
brexit concerns over its just-in-time
manufacturing processes this is the
pinnacle of just-in-time the pinnacle
and if you didn't have that and if it
was delayed as you say by a day because
we were outside of the free-flowing
customs union Arrangements it would just
be a bit of a pain wouldn't it wouldn't
be disastrous what to build a thousand
cars a day without front ends on I think
the customer wouldn't particularly like
that German owned BMW was famously and
repeatedly referred to in the brexit
referendum as a European company that
would force Chancellor Merkel to offer
the UK a greats brexit deal prexy
supporters now actively arguing for no
deal say that this is just companies
sensibly rearranging plans and they
blame the government because their
German and they've got huge political
influence from Germany and they are they
are they are under pressure and they're
being told to say this of course they
didn't want us to leave and make a huge
excessive it because they're worried
that others might want to do the same
what is significant about this
politically is not just that a top
manufacturer has run out of Road in
being able to rely on their being a deal
the timing of this shutdown has a clear
implication a calculation that a No Deal
will cut BMWs supply lines by
effectively shutting the Channel Tunnel
for a week or two after which industry
expects that consequences would be so
disastrous that a government would be
forced back to the negotiating table
within weeks both Jaguar Land Rover and
Honda have expressed severe concerns
about No Deal brexit in recent days but
this mini break from BMW is the first
time a top car manufacturer has directly
blamed No Deal for a significant
production change the government's
reassurances may no longer be working
faisal Islam Sky News